with a vaccine against the new
coronavirus many months if not years
away scientists and doctors are racing
to treat the disease it causes they have
identified antibody testing and blood
plasma therapeutics as promising
approaches to mitigating the health and
economic related fallout from the
pandemic these technologies that could
also help us learn more about how widely
the virus is spread it's based on the
same principle of if you have a
protective antibody passive transfer of
that could provide not only protection
prophylactically but also treatment when
patients recover from a viral infection
they produce virus fighting proteins
known as antibodies these circulate in a
person's blood and help protect against
future infections antibodies are
particular to the invader they're
produced to fight off if they're found
in the blood that means the person was
infected and that they now have the
molecular defenses to fight that virus
off a process known as immunity in
theory dr. Scott transfer these
antibodies to a person who is still sick
so these proteins could help them
recover this kind of therapy has been
tried in the past during previous public
health crises it was used in the 1918
flu epidemic he was using many outbreaks
of mumps polio and measles in the early
20th century and continues to be used as
recently as the SARS epidemic of 2003
the treatment known as convalescent
plasma therapy is gaining traction now
because there aren't other approved
alternatives for treating Koba 19 the
word stopgap is often associated with
and the reason is it is available today
the safety and efficacy haven't been
established yet through clinical trials
which is the gold standard but
preliminary tests in China have shown
encouraging results and in March the FDA
started to allow doctors in the u.s. to
treat some patients with a plasma of
those who have recovered from Cobra 19
for the recipients we are looking for
people who are admitted to a hospital
who are showing increasing oxygen
requirements which indicate to us that
they're on a potentially a downhill
course Mount Sinai in New York is one of
a growing number of house
across the country administering
convalescent plasma to qualifying cope
at 19 patients recovered patients
interested in donating plasma fill out a
survey then to comply with FDA
guidelines clinicians have to put these
potential donors through two tests first
a diagnostic test they have to make sure
they're not still carrying the new
coronavirus and then an antibody test to
ensure they're making enough antibodies
to fight the virus off that second test
looks for antibodies in blood plasma
scientists at Mount Sinai developed an
antibody test by starting with a genetic
code for the virus that serves as the
blueprint for proteins using these
instructions they mass produce synthetic
copies of a protein that the virus has
on its surface then they take special
plates with dozens of tiny wells and
coat the bottom of each one with the
synthetic proteins after that they put
some of the donor plasma into each well
if there are antibodies these recognize
the viral protein and bind to it the
scientists then add an additional
antibody which lights up when it binds
to the synthetic viral protein and
coronavirus antibody combo scientists
run this test at different
concentrations until it stops lighting
up the more they have to deal with the
sample the more antibodies the persons
plasma has the more antibodies the
better the plasma is for therapy
scientists do this kind of testing in
labs all the time but to do it
clinically they need to notify
regulators if a potential donor passes
the virus and the antibody tests then
Mount Sinai clinicians ask them to go to
the New York Blood Center where they can
give enough plasma to administer to
patients then there are two other
hurdles before that plasma can be given
to patients making sure it doesn't have
any other viruses like hepatitis or HIV
and the blood types have to match one
donation can likely treat two people
according to preliminary estimates so
far Mount Sinai has treated more than 30
patients administering the therapy
requires sign-off from the FDA how will
you tell if somebody's getting better
because of this treatment well in about
four or five days of
they'll be recovering more quickly than
other people with similar
characteristics we have a team of
biostatisticians that are starting to
model what happens for patients in our
experience in the health system such as
the length of hospital stay the need for
ICU days the need for ventilator and of
course mortality and survival or of
course the ultimate the treatment is not
without risks transfusion reactions can
include fever allergic reactions and
even lung injury and like the swab tests
that tell somebody if they have the
virus antibody tests are also in short
supply in the long term the hope is that
they could help mitigate some of the
economic effects of the pandemic so
right now I'm talking to you from my
apartment you're in your house in
Baltimore I imagine could this kind of
testing also help policymakers figure
out who is able to go back to work
safely if we knew who has antibody we
and they have recovered you could
imagine that those could go work safer
it would require an enormous undertaking
to test almost everyone in the country
the antibody tests also have to be
highly accurate and recently the
accuracy of some tests developed abroad
has been called into question despite
the challenges scientists are optimistic
that plasma therapy could help patients
recover faster and give them clues about
how deadly the virus really is we don't
know the denominator we don't know the
number of people that have been infected
but did not have disease and and the
presence of antibody in their blood will
identify that subset and you need to
know that number to know really
how lethal this diseases
you